this is max also known as rinhari saki
he's our in-house breath of the wild
expert with over 2 300 hours in the
games he's created techniques
and even has a 99-page combat glossary
and today
as many of you requested he's breaking
down
even more viral and ridiculous breath of
the wild clips who does it the normal
way you want to do the the cool way
with all the glitches and stuff so also
if you have any clips of your own you
want max to watch or even a suggestion
toss them in the comments re-read all of
them and for more videos like this
of course consider giving us a sub okay
take it away max
[Music]
okay
okay cool what we got going on here it
looks like it's at 80 speed run i don't
know who it is
this is a pretty common strat to go to
hyrule castle
and grab these ingredients and then
throw them into the pot this thing that
he's cooking
is a triple attack up boost which is a
huge boost to your attack that you'll
definitely need during the calamity
gannon fight this needs to be cooked
without getting hit by moblins obviously
and this is a technique to get around
those moblins so what he does here was
throw a bomb
to distract one and then sneak strikes
the other one now when an enemy is
sneak-striked they can't hear
or see anything so he uses that time to
cook that boost
and get out of dodge so there's actually
another technique with sneak strikes
called sneak strikes chaining which is
basically
using the speak strike to do it over and
over and you do that by
sneak striking the enemy going to the
other side and then sneak striking again
because they will always look to the
point where you attack them first so
basically
you sneak strike them you turn around go
to the other side and then sneak
striking them again to pretty much do an
infinite on the enemy until they're dead
he's already dead snake strike chaining
isn't used much in speed runs because
there's other
more efficient ways to get enemies
killed and usually just going to get the
weapons
not usually going for the enemy kills so
this is just another
combat strike that you could use in
speed runs
oh i think i know what he's doing
[Music]
already
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this is a technique that's
really cool called cutscene damage
so basically there's a very specific
setup with
very specific points mostly with ganon i
don't know about other
fights mostly with the blight and with
calamity ganon where
you can shoot an arrow in a very very
very specific spot just as you're about
to enter a cutscene
and that arrow will be suspended in
mid-air and since since these cut scenes
are live
and in real time when the boss comes in
it's going to be literally stuck
in that arrow and that arrow's going to
be doing damage live during the cut
scene so that's why you saw his head
kind of freak out because that arrow was
hitting his eye
so basically he's just getting infinite
damage while he's just sitting there
during the cutscene and as soon as a
cutscene stops he's dead immediately
this is pretty useful for any kind of
speed run obviously because the first
boss is dead immediately you can do this
against calamity ganon as well this was
just looks like an 80 percent
run um for you know just the fire blight
ganon at least get them out of the way
so you don't have to deal with the first
blight which is you know obviously going
to be a huge
time saver so he first starts off here
in a very specific setup you have to do
this setup in order to get that arrow in
the
exact place where you need to be because
if you do if you miss
this arrow shot it won't do the cutscene
damage like it's supposed to
i'm pretty sure at some point this was
discovered by somebody accidentally
doing this
and obviously just to kind of randomly
go into the fight and just randomly
shoot off an arrow you're not gonna get
it every single time so this is to
guarantee the arrow to be hitting every
single time and then on top of that what
you want to do
is you want to pause the game because
this will also guarantee
that you have a timing down of you
entering the cutscene perfectly because
what happens is
you hit the start button he does the
attack boost obviously just to get the
attack damage buff
for the fight but he is holding forward
during that pause button so then as soon
as he unpauses
he goes into that cutscene immediately
and uh once you do that correctly then
the boss is dead
insta kill basically so can't argue with
that
[Music]
so that was a cute little uh ragdoll
launch a lot of launch techniques in
this game are based off a ragdoll
while you're while you're in ragdoll um
including enemies and yourself
uh there's just a lot of extra launch
physics around you so if you did that
while you were standing you wouldn't go
nearly as far
so in order to just forcefully initiate
ragdoll like that what you can do
is shield surf you can also shield spin
and as you're doing that
just simply go to your quick menu and
just go to no shield and that'll
basically just
remove the shield from underneath his
feet and make him just fall on the
ground there's a lot more intricate
techniques um to getting around that
section throwing the bomb simply or bomb
flipping
or you know wind bombing i'm sure
there's a lot of other ways around but
that's just another
way to get over that section without you
know having to do the whole
put the bomb on the thing wait for it to
launch who does it the normal way you
want to do the
the cool way with all the glitches and
stuff
so more btb fun btb is bullet time
bounce
this is actually a pretty common one um
that you see pretty often during speed
runs this one's a little variation
though because it's specifically built
looks like for shooting this guardian so
let's start from the beginning here so
basically this is
a bullet time bounce setup uh what he's
doing first is to whistle to get the
buckhoblin's detention to turn around
towards
the outside
and then what he does is shoot an arrow
at a very specific spot to
make the cable distracted and walk over
to that position and then afterwards
you'll be thinking
like why would he just be randomly
swinging axes um on top of this building
like a crazy idiot but that's actually
used for timing these attacks and those
jumps have very specific
amounts of time that's pretty easy to
duplicate if you just you could just
match attack over and over it's going to
have that same swing
speed every single time so that's all
for just timing purposes so you need to
jump off the temple of time in a very
specific time because
the pokolin needs to be at a very
specific place to
make this btb work correctly because the
bokoblin moving around
even looking left to right that will
change your btb because there's a hitbox
around
the enemy that will change your you know
launch trajectory depending on where you
hit
on the enemy and very very minut
differences will cause you to launch in
just completely opposite directions
so you need to have them looking and
facing in a very specific way so bullet
time bounce
is basically a technique where if you're
shield surfing in slow-mo
and you touch an enemy that is
rag-dollable
such as a bokoblin they'll basically rag
doll and just kind of fall to the floor
and that moment causes you to launch
away really quickly and obviously
he used that in conjunction with firing
an arrow to pretty much just fly with
the arrow and follow it and look cool to
shoot that guardian from a massive
you know 14 miles away um so another
just
cool btb shot um obviously these are
super fun to watch a whole bunch of
these on twitter
there's just a whole bunch of creative
ones that people come up with you know
with wind bombs and btbs and all sorts
of launching techniques to make these
look really flashy so
it's just another cool one that we can
see again
so he's utilizing a technique here where
if you
freeze an enemy then stasis them you can
use that to conduct electricity with
shock arrows now he's utilizing more of
that because he's going to slow motion
and so he has more time to do these
shots by doing this
with a five shot lino bow like this he's
doing massive damage so if you think
about it a five shot bow
does five arrows every time that shotgun
touches a frozen and stasis enemy it
will do the conduction
and we'll do the thunder dome and that
thunder dome does 40 damage
so if you think about it he's doing this
over and over and over
40 times three or five over and over and
over in that aoe or you know area of
effect range those enemies are just
toast
doesn't even matter the color the gold
enemy was smart in this case because
they do have the most hp
but pretty much anything in that radius
that's affected by electricity dies so
it's a good way to to cheese
if you want to get past some enemies and
you don't have too much equipment on you
okay uh so this guy is highly in vicky i
think he's doing
some really advanced stuff and this is
actually an accident
so um what happened here oh god this is
this is gonna be the really advanced
stuff
um wait wait he had a fireball come on
hold on oh
oh wow i didn't see that part what the
hell okay so we're gonna explain this in
three different ways we're gonna explain
first just the techniques he used
in order and then we'll explain try to
explain the intricacies of it and
how it actually happened and then i'm
just gonna explain what happened so
first uh he did a deruksio block reset
to get into the air
and then he slowed the route marked the
fireball and then he did another daruk
shield block reset
into an absolute thunderclap rush and he
absolutely thunderclap rushed the air so
what actually
happened here was he was airborne he
used the rook shield block reset to get
into the air that's not important the
important part is what the lionel did so
if the lionel sees the bomb without
seeing you it will instinctively
throw a fireball at it to knock it away
and jump backwards
and what happened was when he placed
that bomb down in the ground the lionel
fireballed him
and hit his deruk's protection so he was
in the air in slow motion with the
rook's protection on and the fireball
hit him that triggered to be marked in
that spot of where the next flurry rush
will be then he just did another
deruccio block reset to get airborne
again and then he did
a thunderclap rush but that thunderclap
brush it's an absolute thunderclap brush
that will go towards that mark that was
set by the fireball in short
he flurry rushed the fireball that's
pretty much what happened
[Music]
all right here's some homework for you
guys this isn't too difficult to do and
once you got the muscle memory down it
becomes super useful in many places in
the game
the basic bomb parry is a flashy and
multi-useful technique that's great for
combat and farming materials
to perform a bomb parry you'll need a
shield and preferably you should switch
to square bombs
you can do this with round bombs but
there's more room for error if it rolls
away
what you'll want to do is stand and hold
zl then jump
then press the bomb button mid-air this
will drop the bomb directly in front of
link
then press the bomb and parry very
quickly in succession
so again that's hold zl x then l
then l and a very quickly if you parry
too early the bomb will hit link
if you parry too late the shield will
break the biggest mistake people make is
if you are out of combat and are not
zl locked onto an enemy the pickup
prompt ruins your parry because link
will attempt to pick up the bomb instead
of pairing it
so while you're out exploring always
back up a couple steps before parrying
if you want to practice this easily
without the hassle of backing off every
time
first grab a couple shields then find
any he knocks out in the open
then start walking until you're close
enough to lock onto it
save your game so you don't lose your
shield to accidentally break then
practice away
don't worry you're far enough away and
the henox won't hear you
after a while you'll get the timing down
and you'll start blowing away your foes
left and right
thanks again for watching and don't
forget to share your own clips and
suggestions in the comments below
[Music]
do
you